So, we've got a new round of FoodShops
pedophile drama.
As happens every few months, FoodShops,
in a totally self-inflicted way, has
drawn massive attention to the fact that
she has called herself a pedophile
repeatedly and described her attraction
to children.
Uh so, we are once again in a new cycle
of FoodShops pedophile drama. So, this
time FoodShops' massive own goal was
posting this.
Hey @TwitchSupport, here is Hasan [__]
blatantly calling me a transgender woman
a pedophile. I'm pretty sure this is
against Twitch TOS to leverage
transphobic insults at me. Clearly,
Hasan is transphobic. He is no ally to
trans people in any way.
So, worth a try, ain't it? Worth a try.
Let's see.
>> I forget what they're called. I think
No, it wasn't Lonerbox. Lonerbox didn't
work. Uh Hutch didn't work. They tried
to like promote Hutch a lot. They tried
to promote Lonerbox a lot, and it didn't
work. And I think um the name was what?
FoodShops? Uh you left out details. She
is an admitted pedophile. Oh, yeah, I
forgot. Um there's also that as well.
Apparently, this person got outed as a
pedophile. Yeah. So, it didn't really
work. It didn't really work. It didn't
uh work at all. She self-admitted. Well,
it turns out I there are ops that I
don't even know exist out there, but one
thing is a guarantee, they are going to
be sex criminals in some variety, some
way, shape, or form.
Um this is like the the primary driving
force behind almost all of my ops. It's
you know, there's a If you exist for a
long enough timeline and you're a an op
of mine, you end up getting into trouble
in this way somehow. I don't know why,
but in any case, That was a clip, guys.
So, that's the clip. So, that's the
bannable clip, apparently. That's what
FoodShops is calling for a ban over.
Now, naturally, Hasan responded to this.
Speaking of pedo ops, this one was also
going after you. Yeah, I saw this
earlier. Um this one is uh trying to get
me banned off off Twitch, but you can't
you can't literally be like, "I'm
transgender, and that's why you're
calling me a pedophile." When you have
literal videos of you admitting to being
a pedophile
on the same [__] platform that you're
trying to get me banned off of. I
literally I have no idea
why you would even try this, genuinely.
The outcome is obvious. Everyone just
posts the clips of you saying it,
and more people think you're a
pedophile.
Hasan's never getting banned for this.
You're just going to make more people
think you're a pedophile.
Like,
"Hey DJ Clancy, this is dangerous to my
life. Keep Twitch a safe platform."
Using it for liberalism to defend
pedophilia is nasty work, Lamonte.
>> I'm only into the most feminine of the
most feminine.
That's what I'm saying. I need to I need
to have a little girl to wrap myself
around.
Oh, like you're like
big spoon is what you're saying?
Oh, I get you.
>> I need to have like a 12-year-old.
What?
Like, what do you mean? I I don't
understand.
Um, someone I saw a tweet on the
timeline that I really thought was
funny. Destiny keeps sending like
different pedophiles
uh Hasan's way. Like, uh
yeah, I saw the dead domain one. Here's
you admitting on camera being attracted
to children. But while I was like
actually covering the topic itself,
right? Um, pedophilia, okay?
[__] I need to say pedo cuz I don't
think Food Shop seems to think she's
adequately addressed it because DGGers
have accepted it, but they haven't. They
hate her. They hate her and call her a
pedophile to hate.
I think YouTube likes it. I don't think
YouTube likes it when I say say that,
okay?
It's fake background. I got you. Yeah, I
figured it out. She also is she sounds
like Destiny, too, which is another one
of the telltale signs.
Like, I don't understand how the [__]
did this
I don't understand how this [__]
community
uh was was designed around this this
interest, but it is what it is, I guess.
But yeah, someone said someone said
Destiny keeps sending uh different
Destiny keeps sending different
pedophiles after Hasan like a Sailor
Moon villain.
Oh.
Um
So obviously because of that, right? And
then I also So there yeah, the deep
tweet the deep tweet liked already
liked. admitted at some point that I
unironically consume loli. So, if you
don't like the fact that I that I
don't like the fact that I consume loli,
you're free to leave, okay?
Um you know, it like that is just a part
of me, you know, like it's it's not like
I can change my attractions or anything
like that, right? But I don't think I'm
a pedophile. I really don't think so.
Um
>> [laughter]
>> Um
Yeah, Destiny orbiter, too, if you can
believe such a thing. Weird how it's
always the exact people you expect.
Yeah.
So yeah, that's
>> Why say this? Like, what's the purpose?
Dude, I don't [__] know, man. I don't
know.
>> it, really. That's about it for the
Hasan response here for for this stream.
Now, we do get a little bit more, guys.
And the little bit more is where this
really becomes relevant to our interests
today. Listen, I'm putting together a
team. Like, we got to get a team going
with like [__] strong liberals, all
right?
>> So, I do have POCD, and I do consume
loli. So, like, you're in the network
now, and maybe we can have some
conversations in the future, and and uh
I would count as a lower P pedophile,
yes. Try to like build up a movement of
uh I need to I need to have have girl to
wrap myself around. I need to have like
a 12-year-old.
I am I am a very strong liberal, that's
for sure. I do talk about politics a
lot. You know, I'm not
>> agree with me, so I
You agree with me, so I assume you're
like really smart, so.
It's the pedo avengers, dude.
I mean, this paired up with the fact
that Hutch said he would vote for
Jeffrey Epstein as long as Jeffrey
Epstein was a Democrat.
>> [screaming]
>> What more can you say? Why is it every
single one of your haters
I mean,
I don't know, man. I don't know.
So,
that's one of the main offending
clips there, guys, okay?
This has set off
quite quite a lot of quite a lot of
drama.
So, you may recognize a lot of the
content of that
compilation there.
Obviously, we've covered much of it. And
that is when Hutch first started having
his little fallout
with
so like Pesco
was entertaining the idea that maybe the
Destiny allegations weren't that bad.
Maybe maybe he was a bit premature in
cutting him off
cuz there's there's new information that
he won't be specific about and will
never actually describe in any way.
Maybe it's not that bad. Maybe you know,
see Sam, not a big deal, maybe.
That's what Hutch started thinking.
And so he went and he jumped on Food
Shop's stream
and was like
because Food Shop's stream title was
Hutch Defense Force or something.
He immediately jumped on Food Shop's
stream and was like, oh,
you'd make a you'd make a great
addition. I'm I'm putting together a
team.
I'm putting together a team.
You'd make a great addition.
Cuz he was that desperate.
And it was obvious at the time
well, this would look [__] terrible.
This looks [__] terrible.
This person like calls himself a
pedophile.
You look like a [__] [__]
This could so easily be used against
you. And lo and behold, it is as we can
see from the song clip.
So, we're going to see a bit more of
what I saw on Hutch to say about about
Hutch around here.
If I can find it again.
And then we'll see what Hutch has been
saying on Twitter today.
His viewers now
in 2019
Oh my
god.
Oh my god.
But back then he wasn't like a [__]
weirdo, right? articles draw numerous
investigations. It's never been hyper
focused on one thing individually. And I
think that that is how it should be
done.
>> in the next 6 months or so. I just cheat
on my wife instead of something crazy
like asking a PDF file to hype Gavin
Newsom for me.
Thank you for $4.20. Thank you.
Especially in the case of someone like
Donald Trump who is insanely corrupt.
Wait, he had 500 viewers back then? He
has less viewers now?
Oh, that's crazy.
He had hair.
He had [__] hair back then. He had
more viewers back then.
God damn, he got cooked. How the [__]
did he lose 100% of his hair and 50% of
his audience?
Tate.
Ended Prime Hutch.
The thing is, Hutch was on Barrel back
then, too. If D isn't live, he can clear
1K and poofs after D goes live. Oh,
that's so sad.
>> [laughter]
>> Do you think he blames you? No.
Bro worked with Machinima back in the
day so he low-key peaked in like '08.
I mean, he was he he wasn't like a
[__] weirdo back then. He was not a
He was not as big as a weirdo back then
at all.
Over the last like 6 years
and uh eating Destiny's
ass crumbs uh to the best of his ability
have turned him into this like weird
[__] liberal monster
who's even more wrong
than than SexPestiny is because
SexPestiny is wrong, but Hutch is wrong
on a delay
because he's waiting for SexPestiny to
say things so he can regurgitate it. So,
then he's wrong on an even larger delay.
It's so sad.
I truly don't understand how you [__]
get to this point where you're like
begging a [__] sub third I'll even
I'll say it.
I actually think as much as Hutch is a
Destiny orbiter,
he's not a Destiny skin walker. I think
he actually thinks those things
independently.
And he doesn't like he does not line up
100%.
They're in the same camp,
but I honestly like there is a
difference. He is an orbiter, but he is
not a he is not a skin walker. He does
not just regurgitate.
He has come to those positions in some
way
separate to Destiny.
And that like I said, it isn't a Hutch
and crossover and the thought process
just isn't the same either. Like a lot
of the time
you can tell someone's gotten the
positions from Destiny when they start
talking through it, right?
When when you hear someone start talking
about like um
like ethical CP,
right?
You you the moment you start hearing
like the dialogue trees, you're like,
"Oh, I literally I know
where you heard that." Or like some sort
of stuff about like the incest stuff.
The moment you're hearing someone talk
about like
oh, two gay brothers that are
separated at birth, twins,
never met each other and meet at
university like, you know, do you know
what I mean?
The The exact talking talking points,
the exact dialogue tree.
And you're like, okay, I know where
you've got that from.
When when Hutch talks about things,
it does just come off more like like it
does just seem like it's Hutch engaging
with the news.
It doesn't seem like Hutch engaging with
what he heard on the Destiny stream.
Pretty
uh pedophile YouTuber, they're not even
a pedophile YouTuber, but like a
pedophile streamer that is like
just another chatter from the sex pest
and he sex called
for for an allegiance so you can build a
pedo uh neoliberal Avengers like
very very sad.
His last vod has 84 views, not 84K, 84
views. Oh.
I also don't get it like a whole ass
grown ass man just got captivated by
another grown ass man. You can see that
his career completely flatline when he
became a deorbiter in 2021. His
following was growing and it hit a brick
wall. If you look at his SG,
you can see the exact point he destroyed
his career, negative following since
2021, lol.
Forgot that I was watching you
>> League of Sta- story gentlemen, preteen
Titans.
Anyway, here's a few bucks to support
your antisocial lifestyle. Thank you for
the $5, thank you. Huge appreciate,
thank you. Union of groom.
Like if you have your own The thing is
his last chat in here was him rating
you, lol. The thing is
if you have your own personal opinion,
you can carve out a place for yourself.
Like you can always carve out a place
for yourself, you can carve a community
out for yourself, but if you're like
hyper focusing on building an audience
from another person's audience, like
you're always going to be at their
mercy.
Like Michael from Pennsylvania and I
disagree from time to time on issues. A
lot of people be like, "Oh, yo, Mike,
you're dick riding Hasan or whatever the
fuck." First of all, he has his own
opinions, he has his own development, I
have mine, and we have our own
community. Sure, our communities
obviously intertwine with one another,
but
the reality of the matter is like, there
are things that he says that I don't
agree with. There are things that I say
that he doesn't agree with. It's
perfectly fine, it's perfectly normal.
But, these guys don't do that. They
don't have any investment whatsoever in
a political project where there can be
like any room for disagreement
whatsoever. He's just like
they they consistently project their own
[__] personal insecurities for not
have
for not having established their own
world view or have their own opinions on
other people where they're like, "Oh,
you guys you have orbiters." Like,
that's not the case.
I have people who I collaborate with. I
have peers. I don't have [__]
orbiters.
He's so humble.
Almost all the debate panel streamers
hate you because you didn't collaborate
with them.
Yeah.
Is there any more to that?
It's just a very
sad state of affairs, honestly, for how
these guys operate, how these guys live,
how these guys have have existed for
like years at this point.
How do you [__] do that [__] for
years, man? How?
Whoops. Hasan [__] reacts to Hasan
[__] calling Food Shops a pedo. Call,
they think Hasan calling blatantly
calling me a transgender woman a
pedophile? I forget what they're called.
I think No, it wasn't Lonerbox. Lonerbox
didn't work. Uh Hutch didn't work. They
tried to like promote Hutch a lot. They
tried to promote Lonerbox a lot. It's
crazy Hasan's getting called transphobic
nowadays more than I am. I mean, it's
really a big shift.
>> Food Shops? Uh you left out details. She
>> [__] videos about me, too. An admitted
pedophile. Oh, yeah. An admitted Why is
everybody nowadays a pedophile to Hasan?
I forgot. Um there's also
But he said it's not like he said
allege pedophile.
He didn't just call her a pedophile.
No, it was stated that she's an admitted
pedophile. And yeah, Asmongold doesn't
need to go
Why is everyone a pedophile to this guy?
Well, probably because
the admitted part.
Also that as well. Apparently this
[music] person Everybody is like
>> Yeah. So it didn't really work. It
didn't really work. It didn't uh work
>> What does that have to Wait, what? What
are you even talking about? Well, it
turns out I There are ops that I don't
even know exist out there, but one thing
is a guarantee, they are going to be sex
criminals in some variety, some way,
shape, or form. Um this is like the the
primary driving force behind almost all
of my ops is Everybody hates you because
they're like sex freaks. Okay.
You know, there's a If you exist for a
long enough timeline and you're an op of
mine, you end up getting into trouble in
this way somehow. I don't know why, but
in any case, I forget what Man, that's
weird. And uh Hasan's going through the
Asmongold cycle. I guess so. Yeah,
everybody's getting mad at him for this
and uh I really honestly like And now
they're getting angry at him for, you
know, calling people pedos and stuff
like this. I think he needs to calm down
with like making random stuff. I guess
he moved on from Israel. It's just
That's usually what the language is.
Hasan [__] calls out Asmongold for
defending food shops. Let's see this.
Food shops? Uh you left out details.
She's
>> Yeah, this [__] makes videos about me,
too. An admitted pedophile. Oh, yeah.
>> An admitted Why is everybody nowadays a
pedophile to Hasan?
I wonder why
I wonder why Asmongold constantly finds
himself defending people who are
self-admitted pedophiles. Interesting.
Mhm.
This one, well, she says it out loud.
It didn't really [music] work. It didn't
What does that have to wait what? What
are you even talking about? Well, it
turned I like that he will just watch
like a clip like this and will just not
investigate it at all and will turn
around and be like, "What is he talking
about?" That's enough. That's the
commentary from him. Asmongold, of
course, highlighting the clip hoping
that it actually gets traction.
Um
is is once again finding himself
defending yet another, you know,
self-declared, self-admitted lolicon
enjoyer, pedophile. Everybody hates you
because they're like sex freaks. Okay.
Yeah, I mean, look, I don't I don't
think so. I didn't think so.
Okay, I didn't think so. This is how it
keeps unfolding.
This is crazy.
I don't know why Asmongold keeps
defending these people, but
turns out that you don't need to be
friends with Asmongold for him to defend
their sex pest. I know.
It's kind of crazy. It's kind of crazy
that he is like, you know,
This one, apparently, this person had
made videos about Asmongold, too, and
he's still defending her.
So, at that point, I assume there's a
second reason. Is it because like
they're a self-identifying pedophile? Is
that what it is? Asmongold defended
Chibi Reviews
and then ended up defending
the this this pedo shops.
This other
pedo reviews and pedo shops. Incredible
stuff. So,
I think those are all the clips.
So, let's see. How did Hutch choose to
respond to some of this stuff, guys.
It's not good.
I'm going to say now, it's not good.
So, you see here uh Tony, this is the
original clip uh that the compilation.
And then Hutch replies to it here.
Wait a second.
And then it's
the lol overall thing
where Hassan says
it was creep [__] and cut ties.
So, Hutch's defense
against someone saying
Hutch, you
are knowingly
trying to form a coalition, a team
with a pedophile.
What's the deal there?
His response to that is
well
Hassan said his friend was a creep when
he
got allegations against him.
So, that's that's an interesting
response. So,
at the best of times
responding to criticisms of your own
actions with winding up a Hassan is not
a great sign.
But, that's at the best of times.
In this instance, the thing he's
pointing to is actually Hassan doing the
right thing under these
sort of terms.
Whereas Hutch
appears to be doing the totally wrong
thing.
Now, if I remember correctly, I don't
think this guy like what did this guy
even do? He was like slightly pushy on
Snapchat or some [__] right?
Who chops his a self-described
pedophile?
pedophile, Hutch?
And someone replies, "As soon as he
found out, he disavowed and cut ties."
And Hutch goes
"Since when does this matter?"
The most raped man on Twitter.
Now, after he started posting this, he
got a bunch of Dan Saltman followed
accounts
replying to him saying apparently some
black guy Hassan hangs out with who's
got felonies for rape or some [__]
So, he's just going So, people call him
out for orbiting Destiny as well. People
say He says, "If one Discord call in a
year featuring a political debate over
upholding versus ending institutional
norms counts as orbiting, then someone
still being friends with plus regularly
hanging out with someone kicked out of
Harvard for accused rape means the
someone is literally attached to the hip
of said rapist, correct?"
So, I literally I don't even know who
the guy I just told you about is.
>> to me seven times over three hours with
the exact same joke about his cousin
being a child enjoyer in 2013.
He is genuinely losing it. I've seen
that.
Ape Gamer, thank you for the $5. We'll
pull it up. Yeah, I don't I don't know
what the deal is with this black guy. I
literally have no idea.
No one knows who he is.
Hasan derives a significant part part of
his uh career success from Destiny and
orbiting Destiny. It's just blatantly
true.
Um
So, yeah. One minute. Let's Let's pull
this thread up. Let's pull this thread
up.
So, yeah. He quote tweets her.
So, I got it it's Just let's actually
just um
remind ourselves of the clip again,
actually. I think it's a good moment to
Hasan had to disavow an actual
self-admitted sex pest that he regularly
collaborated with last summer, correct?
If me having two Discord conversations
with someone means I own their edgelord
jokes. So, even their desperate sweeping
edgelord jokes, bro.
Hasan for sure owns his friend's rampant
sexual harassment, correct?
So, let's
take a look.
Okay. Listen, I just wanted to, you
know, stop by and say what's up. Um but,
listen, I'm putting together a team.
Like, we got to get a team going with
like [__] strong liberals, all right?
>> So, I do have POCD and I do consume
lolly. So, like, you're in the network
now and maybe we can have some
conversations in the future and and uh I
would count as a lower P pedophile, yes.
Try to like build up a movement of uh I
need to I need to have a little girl to
wrap myself around. I need to have like
a 12-year-old. I am I am a very strong
liberal, that's for sure. I do talk
about politics a lot. You know, I'm not
Well, you agree with me, so I
you agree with me, so I assume you're
like really smart, so
So okay, we've reminded ourselves that
clip. Sorry, I don't want to say what
date or quickly. I have to look at this.
Streaming into a slot machine engagement
[__] exploiting human weakness on
the most fundamental level.
Wow, we got we got the we got the
esteemed Marxist Leninist in the chat,
dude. Oh my god, you are so [__]
intellectual and so well-read. I don't
know if you know this, but I'm a [__]
Twitch streamer, dumbass.
Do you understand? Do you understand
that? Like you're Stop being Stop
looking for something more intellectual
here, okay?
Do you understand? Wee-woo wee-woo, it's
the [__] fun police up in this [__]
Jesus Christ.
No fun allowed. Soundboard is necessary
for the whole to hold the attention of
zoomers. Yeah, soundboard exploitation.
It's just
It's [__] crazy. It's crazy. Here's
what I have to SAY TO YOU.
THIS GUY'S SO OLD. THAT'S WHAT SHE SAID.
WOW, YOU GOT BUTT SLAMMED.
LISTEN. OKAY. IT FEELS LIKE YOU'RE
TURNING YOUR STREAM
OKAY.
So what you're saying is to disavow the
sex pest who you as of right now
continue to align and refuse to disavow
self-admitted pedophile Food Shops just
because he's friends with Destiny.
Didn't you refuse to speak to Q and just
because he called you a Destiny orbiter?
First of all, I have actually zero idea
of anything you're talking about.
Yeah, you do.
Secondly, if I'm aligned with Food Shops
because we had two civil conversations
about politics. So, I'm almost
positively attached to the hip
with an admitted and rampant sex pest.
How do we know he didn't know what was
going on if he was attached to the hip?
Hutch, I'm not a Hasan fan at all, so
deflecting to Hasan won't work on me.
Saying what FoodShop said is just
edge lord jokes and disgusting level of
a sweep.
Ask me if I give one singular flying
[__]
So, it's bad when Hasan disavows a sex
pest he used to hang out with.
But you don't give a singular flying
[__] that everyone is watching you
knowingly and proudly associate with a
self-described pedophile who said her
17-year-old ex had a lolly body.
And you're helping Dems win how?
Would you ask me to disavow your cousin?
I've disavowed every pedophile I've come
into contact with. Can you say the same?
Oh, you're pulling it together a team of
them. I wonder if that's anything to do
with Destiny stating on Dan's podcast
that 16 should be the
national age of consent.
Or maybe when he said 14-year-olds are
hot. It was 15, for sure.
Have you disavowed my cousin's
problematic social media post from 2013,
you [__] piece of [__] This is the
fourth time you've brought up your
cousin in response to me.
Are we reactivating some kind of
suppressed childhood trauma by
complaining about a pedophile?
The point is it's performative to have
to disavow literally everything you have
even the mildest association with. That
cashier you just said thank you to for
bagging your food.
Well, they know your uncle and that
cashier served lolly when they were 12
years old. Disavow. Mildest association,
they're friends. You called her into a
stream to get her on the team and told
her welcome to the network. Now he's
adamantly defending you on Twitter.
Would you call that a mild association?
If I'm friends with FoodShop's, you're
friends with my cousin. It's very
disgusting that you haven't disavowed
their problematic tweets from 2013, you
son of a [__]
So, it you're right here.
Hutch. But okay. Look, I just wanted to,
you know, stop by and say what's up. Um,
but listen, I'm putting together a team.
Like we got to get a team going of like
[__] strong liberals, all right? So,
I do have POCD and I do consume lolly.
So, like, you're in the network now and
maybe we can have some conversations in
the future and and uh I would count as a
lower P pedophile, yes. Try to like
build up a movement of uh I need to I
need to have a little girl to wrap
myself around. I need to have like a
12-year-old.
I am I am a very strong liberal, that's
for sure. I do talk about politics a
lot. You know, I'm not really a
political
>> with me, so I
you agree with me, so I assume you're
like really smart, so.
Awesome stuff, really.
And then we see here, you're looping.
Are you okay? How much Vyvanse have you
snorted today? I heard abusing that [__]
can cause short-term memory loss.
Tankies turning into ableists as soon as
it's convenient. Like, these people are
just so lost.
These people are just so lost, man.
No one here is a tankie, [__] idiot.
Hey, lolicons as she claims she has to
cross the street to avoid touching kids.
I'm putting together a little team of
people like Destiny and Empath I touch
kids chan so that she can so we can stop
the Islamic communist world order from
overthrowing the Democratic Party. Are
you with me?
To reiterate, I'm not deep in the trench
of the internet you apparently reside
in. No, you're just calling into food
shop streams at 4:00 in the morning.
And I have zero [__] clue what you're
talking about, like, literally zero.
Calling into food shop streams at 4:00
in the morning, stream 6-plus hours a
day,
on Twitter all day,
not in the trenches of the internet.
Zero clue about anything
you're talking about, like, literally
zero. You know what all of that means.
You know what literally there's not a
single thing in any of these tweets
that he should have a problem
understanding.
Asking me what I have to say about I
just said about the cousin [__] again.
It's just like [__]
Hatch literally could not have a
conversation about this. He would get
raped in any conversation about this.
Oger boy totally raped him on the stuff
yesterday. He had to like literally opt
out of the conversation. He was like,
"We're not doing this. We're not doing
this."